decenas de policías algunos con cascos y
chalecos antibalas esperan frente a la
casa del ex Primer Ministro de Pakistán
afirman que han esconde a personas
implicadas en las violentas protestas
contra su reciente detención a primera
hora del día han recibió un ultimátum
entregar a los 40 sospechosos
relacionados con las manifestaciones o
enfrentarse a una redada policial el
miércoles en una declaración por video
hande dijo que esperaba ser detenido
nuevamente
Acabo de enterarme de que he dado
Refugio a 40 terroristas en mi casa
y se lanzará una operación para detener
a los 40 terroristas
mi petición es que si hay 40 terroristas
en mi casa mi vida también corre peligro
pero no lancen una sala
destituido el año pasado por una moción
de censura en el parlamento se enfrenta
actualmente a más de 100 causas entre
ellas un caso de corrupción en conjunto
con su esposa en las manifestaciones que
siguieron atención en la semana pasada
10 personas murieron y más de 4.000
fueron detenidas el pasado viernes Hank
quedó en Libertad bajo fianza durante
dos semanas por decisión del tribunal
superior de islamabad pero su equipo
jurídico teme que pueda ser arrestado
por casos antiguos el martes o los
líderes civiles y militares de Pakistán
que sospechan que han organizó las
protestas declararon que los
alborotadores y sus partidarios serían
juzgados por las leyes del ejército Pero
según los ataques a instalaciones
militares formaban parte de una
conspiración para desencadenar una lucha
entre su partido y los militares